frankie's gonna try and continue the
good karma it'll be his ninth start in
the season and he could use good karma
right here at minute maid park it's been
rough for him at minute maid in 2021
carrying a 7.32 era at home
he's a gold glover we know that and he
makes the play on the comebacker off the
bat of willie calhoun nice play by zach
to start this game oh two pitch grounded
to bregman solac hustling down the line
makes it close but alex's throw on the
money
two ground outs to start tonight's game
a little tapper
zack's going to get a couple of assists
in the inning as he fields that one
hopper on the mound
and low retired three ground ball outs
quite a start for zach
lefty wes benjamin on the mound for the
rangers owen wanna
cra in three games wasting no time here
against garcia no two fastball at the
bottom of the zone
called strike three so a nice job by
west benjamin to kick things off here in
the first
here's another breaking ball that is hit
into center field but plenty of room out
there for
garcia he makes the catch and the inning
is
over so here is adoles garcia leading
off the second inning facing
zach crinkey swinging a miss that gets
him zach has been looking good
tonight he has thrown his pitches for
strike he's strikes he's getting ahead
of counts and he picks up his first
strikeout
gets it with the change up down also
kind of recognize that garcia was a
little more aggressive on some of these
pitches in the lower part of the zone
and continued to attack down there until
he got the swing and miss
this ball on the ground one big hop
ariel will use that cranky covering
for the final out of the inning zach has
induced
five ground balls through two innings he
is retired all six
nearly still leading the team in walks
with 18. he's been leading all season
long in that category and takes number
19 here
on a 3-2 pitch there goes eule again
pitch is low ball four that'll be a walk
the astros have two runners on third
walk allowed by
benjamin that ball's a base hit up the
middle around third comes guerrielle
he's gonna score heading to third correa
rbi single kyle tucker the hitting
streak up
to six in the astros lead one to nothing
laid off the pitch on the outside corner
and eventually got a pitch he could
handle and shot it back up the middle
miles straw into center field on an o2
pitch with a single that'll drive in
correa
astros in front two to nothing one thing
we've noticed with
miles recently is the shift has not been
being played against him and he's done a
very good job of staying up the middle
this one a line drive would have been a
base hit even if they were
playing him in that shift situation with
a defender behind second base
faces juice astros got him right where
they want him
michael drives one to center field
pretty well hit garcia back on it makes
the play
tucker will score easily heading to
third is straw
and the astros tack on her run on the
sac fly by brantley it's now a
three-nothing game
that's going to push west benjamin out
of here ground ball towards short
played a second for the force out and
bregman
bounces into a fielder's choice to end
the inning but the astros score
three runs in the second isaiah kind of
fluffy leading it off here in the third
inning against that crank you
know two and lined into left field
that's gonna be a base hit and probably
more for
isaiah conor for left as he hustles into
second it'll be an easy
stand-up double for the rangers
shortstop isaiah connor club one of the
top
contact men in this rangers lineup pitch
in off the plate
only at 87 miles an hour we talked about
the velocity is not there but
connor philippa does a really good job
of pulling his hands in
first pitch to trevino line drive right
field just inside the line of base hit
it kicks off the uh angled portion of
the seating bowl
right out to tucker so he fires it back
into second
but scoring on the play is kiner falefa
it's an opposite field rbi
single for the native of south texas
jose trevino
and the rangers are on the board here at
3-1
there is a line drive up the middle
jordan alvarez smokes a single to center
to start this inning the astros have
their lead off runner on for the second
straight inning
there's a ball off to gus that'll be a
base hit
alvarez and guerrielle putting a scare
into this reliever
as he waves off the medical staff the
ball must have hit him in the glove
3-1 pitch low ball four correa draws a
walk
for the second straight time that'll
load up the bases for the astros hottest
hitter
over the last week kyle tucker there's a
ball in the left field dropping quickly
that'll be down for a hit
in to score jordan alvarez his team
leading 25th run of the year
astros lead 4-1 outside
ball four bases loaded walk brings in a
run
astros lead 5-1 straw with his 14th rbi
of the year
correa on third he walked tucker on
second he's single and then straw on
first he had a bases loaded walk
now three due to maldonado and that is
just a little bit in
close maldi takes it for a bases loaded
walk in his third rbi of the year
see if robel garcia can get into the act
he grounds one towards short
glove there by connor falefa gets the
out at second in a double play
turn garcia hits into a twin killing a
run does score
trailing seven to one nick solac will
get it started here in the fourth
nick solak lines one to left field and
that's going to get over the head of
mike grant michael brantley
and take a strange almost 90 degree
bounce to the right
in the oddness that is the left field
gap at minute maid park but it's a
lead off double for nick solak yeah a
really good swing
and chris davis lists a fly ball to deep
right field but not quite deep enough as
tucker is there nick solac will tag up
and score
garcia will stay at first and so it is a
sac fly
for chris davis as the rangers get one
back from the astros
correa hits it hard into right field
that's a base hit carlos correa on base
for the third time tonight
a couple of walks and now a hit he's a
leadoff base runner for the astros in
the fifth
that ball into right center field
that'll be down for a hit miles straw in
base for the third time and it gets past
garcia
correa is going to score straws going to
hold up
carlos correa crosses the plate to make
it an eight to two game
miles straw and correa having big nights
bottom party order is having a very good
night
martin maldonado drives one deep to left
field
and gone maldonado
a two-run home run puts the astros into
double figures it's now
a 10-2 game tried to come in
with a little bit of a slider and that
ball was pummeled
open it up let the barrel get after it
the rest is up in the seats astros are
the 10-2 lead over the rangers top of
the sixth inning
pretty good fastball there by zach in
account where you would think
chris davis was expecting fastball
getting a little bit of a cut motion it
seems like with that
he does seem like he gets on the side of
those every once in a while and creates
a little movement
swing and a miss on the curveball zach
grenky threw
six innings that's 12 consecutive starts
against the rangers where zach has gone
at least six innings
he's leading 10-2 mccormick pinch
hitting here for
michael brantley well there is a
fastball at 97
and it's lifted to right field doll is
back leaps and he
makes the catch david dahl tremendous
catch up against the wall and garcia
goes back to first base and doll all
smiles
after fighting off some houston astros
fans and pulling that one back in
well mccormick did make the adjustment
he hit the fastball a ton but dahl was
on it right from the start
got a great jump on it goes up into the
stands and wow
does a backwards somersault we didn't
quite know if he had the baseball or not
but look at that elevation
going up over the wall enough to where
his elbow
was up over the wall look at that
vertical
man what an extremely athletic play
so adolescarcia will step in one for two
tonight with a walk and he swings to the
first pitch breaking ball and drills it
to left field
and that ball is gone adoles garcia
all over a first pitch breaking ball
from kent emanuel
and that is the tenth home run for
garcia this season
big man does it again enjoying a nice
little trot
around the bases i don't think astros
fans are enjoying it quite as much but
now it came in with good numbers emanuel
did but
he had given up three home runs this is
number four on the season and 10 for
garcia
you can't throw that little get me over
breaking ball to me he says
and he absolutely unloads on it knew it
was gone right off the bat
as did everybody else in the ballpark
joe smith on the mound for the astros
here in the ninth inning
ground ball towards the middle correa
glove flip bare hand robel
safe at first that would have been one
of the prettier double plays of the year
but isaiah kinder philippa getting down
the line turns it into a fielder's
choice
chopper towards third bregman to second
for one garcia double play game over
astros have taken the first two games of
this series against
the rangers they are now six
and two on the home stand with joe smith
wrapping up appearance number 799 in his
career